toine bonjour quelle est donc la
situation sur place oui bien les
autorités sanitaires ont enregistré une
hausse significative des contaminations
a même confirmé vous l'avez dit un
premier décès il s'agit d'une femme de
79 ans hospitalisé depuis le 13 mars
elle a dans un premier temps été prise
en charge dans une clinique privée avant
ensuite d'être transférés dans un
hôpital dédié aux maladies infectieuses
elle était alors traités tout en étant
isolées du reste de l'hôpital la
patiente souffrait à l'origine de
plusieurs maladies comme le diabète
l'athérosclérose encore l'hypertension
c'est donc le premier décès
comptabilisés par les autorités russes
pour cause de covile 19 alors alors
à l'heure actuelle vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure 147 personnes sont
contaminées alors que plus de 22 mille
autres restent sous surveillance
médicale et 80 des 85 régions de russie
sont en état d' alerte élevé pour cause
de coronavirus maintenir poutine s'est
voulu cependant rassurant en affirmant
que la situation était sous contrôle
mais il a également déclaré pas plus
tard que ce matin qu'il fallait se
préparer à tous les scénarios possibles
la population aide surtout à moscou
s'empresse d'acheter des masques dans
les pharmacies tandis que les magasins
d'alimentation commence à être pris
d'assaut comme on a pu le voir dans
certains pays d'europe
avant l'adoption des mesures de
confinement antoinat merci à beaucoup
pour toutes ces précisions